(crinkling)
- People have told me I
have saved their life.
(crunching)
I became a ASMR artist on YouTube.
Because I deal with my own pain each day.
(tapping)
ASMR has truly helped me focus on living
instead of dying.
Close your eyes.
(tapping)
(shaking)
(crunching)
An ASMR artist is someone who focus mainly
on visual triggers and sounds to bring you
some type of relaxation.
Some of the misconceptions
that people have with ASMR
is thinking that it's creepy,
it's cringey, it's weird,
and I believe the reason
why some people believe that
ASMR is so weird is because
I'm constantly whispering.
I'm going to take a sip of
my hot coffee for a second.
But when ASMR artists' whisper,
it's to bring you to that safe place.
It's to make you feel calm.
Tell yourself, “You're going to be okay."
I find my sounds in any
and everything that I do.
(crinkling)
If I'm opening up a pack of
gum, if I'm brushing my hair,
people love crunch sounds
like the pickle video.
I'll snack.
(crunching)
I don't know what happens.
Why does eating a pickle
causes a person's brain
to shut down, but it will.
(crunch)
Wow. Yeah.
I have a degenerative bone disease.
I can't stop it, there's no cure.
Before I discovered
ASMR, I could not move.
I didn't have the strength
to make myself stand up.
So, when I discovered ASMR,
I felt extremely relaxed.
I feel like I was actually
smiling just laying there.
I felt really, really good mentally.
More so than being on medication.
And I said, “Okay, I'm
going to create a channel,
and I'm going to create
ASMR videos because there's
a lot of people who are
dealing with stress, insomnia,
anxiety; who just need some comfort
to get them through the night."
I receive email from
people who are bed ridden
and let me know how
much I have helped them.
I always told my children
one person could change the world.
And to actually be a part
of maybe some type of change
in some type of way, is amazing.